just hours after Russia and China
discussed a peace proposal for Ukraine
Moscow Unleashed a new wave of deadly
attacks on civilian areas yesterday
using missiles and drones Ukraine's
President says Russia is really not
interested in ending this conflict
conflict rather Remy inocencio reports
from the capital city of Kiev
this must not become just another day
said Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski a Russian missile slammed into
this apartment Block in the Southeast
city of zaparisa reducing home's trouble
killing one and injuring dozens
hours earlier Russian drones struck the
town of rajeshif about 40 miles south of
Kiev leaving gaping holes in a college
and two dormitories killing at least
nine this husband and wife inside
fearing they would die
I felt the temperature of my body going
up so much that I thought I would burn
alive
president zielinski in a surprise visit
to the front lines greeted
battle-hardened soldiers fighting in the
East holding a minute of silence for the
Fallen
across the front lines Ukraine taking
more losses while holding back Russian
advances at cost to life in Lynn
everything was on fire Russian soldiers
and our own guys too were dead on the
ground people were running mines were
exploding the face of Ukrainian soldiers
fighting for their lives and Country Now
on the eve of its 14th month or CBS
morning's raymie inocencio Kiev